انذار من الدرجه الخطيره يقرع اجراسا
مخيمات الناجحين السوريين لتتزمن الماساه
الانسانيه مع ازمه صحيه المنظمات المحليه
والدوليه في شمال غربي سوريا حذرت من
ارتفاع في اعداد الاصابه بالكوليرا بشكل
غير مسبوق خاصه بين النازحين في المخيمات
العشوائيه
تضم عشرات المخيمات فيها اكثر من نصف
مليون ناجح اصبحوا الان معرضين لخطر
الكوليرا لتكون الظروف الخدميه لديهم
عاملا مساعدا لانتشار الجرثومه
النازحون يعيشون حاله من الخوف والقلق
البالغين بعد تسجيل ست وفيات بمرض
الكوليرا والاشتباه باكثر من 50 حاله
مصابه بالمرض ذاته قبل ايام
الاعداد التراكميه للفتره الماضيه في شمال
غرب سوريا وصلت الى 20 حاله وفاه
والاصابات سجلت
37,500 منها 6000 خلال الشهر الحالي وافقي
مديريه صحه ادلب مع استمرار تفشي المرض
تبقى الارقام عرضه للزياده ويبقى الاطفال
الاكثر ضرارا
المديريه ذاتها اكدت ان دفعه من اللقاحات
ستدخل المنطقه تم تقديمها من قبل اليونيسف
والتحالف العالمي للقاحات الى عمر العربيه